i gotta share though
with you guys and the listeners you know
anybody who's trying to impress somebody
uh female or male whatever you think
whatever you're into
um i asked him i'm like dude
i asked peter north i'm like he's at my
house we're having a party and they're
writing well dude
how the [ __ ] do you when you [ __ ]
come do you hit the front of this truck
from here like
how is that possible he goes i'll tell
you my secret
i go i go all right he goes
the night before he [ __ ] he ground he
sticks in a blender two but two bushels
like the whole thing of celery
and the fiber in the celery [ __ ]
and and all the liquid in the celery
make you [ __ ]
uh have that much ropes that much jizz
and then he goes what i'll do is i'll
also drink about a gallon
of um pineapple juice because that makes
your [ __ ] [ __ ] taste sweet
and i was like thanks for the advice
and it [ __ ] works the celery dude the
celery and pineapple juice
works everybody's buying celery right
now yeah
amazon prime [ __ ] i mean people got
tape measures out dude i shot it [ __ ]
four foot six bro i mean dude when i
have the pineapple juice
there's no measuring because it's going
right in my mouth
[Laughter]
that's awesome yeah some girl told me
she's like i don't trust a man who
hasn't tasted his own [ __ ]
i've never tasted it i've never tasted
[Laughter]
yeah i can't wrap my head around it but
it's salty wasn't it
didn't you do some [ __ ] up yeah
somebody jerk off into a [ __ ] condom
yeah i did dude i did swallow
pontius [ __ ] yes that's yeah that finally
came out i got it live on my website
dude i got that whole [ __ ] crazy
special
is it is it visible yeah i have to see
that get ready this is going to be
gnarly
pretty gnarly kind of normal are we
ready
[Music]
what's up denver
women can paint their boobs and show
them on instagram
so i figure i should be able to paint my
dick and do whatever i want
make some noise for my brother
[Applause]
wait let me inspect for crabs this time
[Music]
when my buddies lit that stuff right
away i knew
i [ __ ] up
[Music]
i'm not doing this to hurt your dad
you're gonna hurt me you're gonna piss
me off